bonjour damim aujourd'hui expli comment
choisir ces
plantes donc 5 conseil azote avant de de
faire une plantation choisir ses plantes
en fonction du
lieu mais déjà si on habite dans les EAU
donc il y a des plantes spécifiques des
haut par rapport à la température et si
on habite dans les bas donc la
température sera plus haute donc d'AP
prendre des plantes qui soient adapté à
cette
température la deuxème réflexion c'est
où on va planter C ces plantes là donc
si c'est c'est du plein soleil ou ombre
ou mi ombre donc bien bien bien savoir
l'emplacement et comment comment il est
comment il est exposé
quoi
donc ici ici dans ce massif on a mis
plusieurs types de plantes donc on a
mélangé les plantes annuelles bisannuel
et on a mis un couvr-sol aussi donc tous
ces espèces peuvent être plantés à côté
ça pose pas de problème les plantesaliel
ici là c'est du du silosie donc l'annuel
c'est il va fleurir tout au long d'une
seule année donc au bout au bout d'une
année il faudra faudra forcément changer
la plante c'est c'est son cyle naturel
quoi ensuite il y a ici c gofrénia c'est
du on va appeler ça l'immortel c'est non
vernaculaire les gens appellent ça
immortel donc lui il va fleurir pendant
2 ans donc comme
l'annuel au bout de 2 ans il va il va
s'affaiblir et les fleurs va va
commencer à à s'estomper donc plus feu
raison ça peut arriver normalement il y
a il y a cette implant bisannuel il va
fleurir deux fois dans l'année donc ça
va donc avec un bon entretien ça
fleurira plus beaucoup plus vite et plus
longtemps ici aussi il y a du couvr-sol
donc ça ça va donner des des petites
fleurs tout le long de l'année mais avec
aussi avec un bon entretien ça va rester
plus longtemps que que les bisannuel que
l'annuel il y aura moins d'entretien car
le couvrsol ça sert à à déf F les
mauvais se développer
dessousci au jardin r on a choisi
plusieurs plantes donc on a diversifié
les
plantes et donc le conseil pratique
c'est de de bien se faire conseiller en
pépinière car ça coûte très cher les
plantes et ça fera une économie déjà
d'eau d'énergie et on va prendre plus du
plaisir à jardiner et de s'occuper de
ces plantes
là conseil mais c'est jardin donc fait s
en fonction de humeur chois les plantes
que que tu veux et voilà donc faut pas
se prendre la tête faut rester toujours
avec le plaisir et l'amour des plantes
c'est ça c'est ça le principal